you could get a million comments that
say you're beautiful you're amazing
you're this year that and then the one
comment that's like not that's a
negative comment you're like if you
can't take it to heart and it like
really affects you Kendall Jenner gets
candid about those online haters the 23
year old model covers allures March
issue and gets real about how social
media trolls have affected her quote I
have cried endlessly for days because of
things people have said to me and I've
had to become stronger through it I mean
don't get me wrong I am not superhuman I
definitely feel and the things people
say online are very hurtful you also
just have to live your life and not pay
attention to it she added I think it can
get pretty unhealthy if you really are
deep in it and paying attention to it
all the time I think that that's what
can really mess you up Jenner told ET in
2015 that she had learned to ignore the
comments section you're always gonna
have haters and negative comments so we
try not to read them but also got candid
about her biggest insecurity with Al or
her acne something she struggled with
since her teen years
she told the mag quote it's something
that I look at myself in the mirror
every day and see like I don't want it
there but you have to deal with what you
have right in front of you and I had to
deal with it
Kendall's battle with acne became an
unexpected topic of discussion after the
2018 Golden Globes then I remember going
online and seeing all the horrible
things people were saying about me and
my skin I felt so good that I completely
forgot that I had bad skin then I
remember getting a couple tweets that
became a lot of tweets of how proud
people were
I was like oh wait this is actually kind
of cool and it completely flipped my
energy on it Jenner spoke more about
acne while answering fan questions for
allure it sucks it really sucks there is
light at the end of the tunnel I promise
you drink your water I know everyone
says that drink water wash your face
stay clean stay healthy there is a light
at the end of the tunnel and we're gonna
figure this out together and she dished
out advice to young girls struggling
with their self-esteem I personally
think that keeping people around you
that are like awesome and that like lift
you up make you feel great and genuinely
good people around you that it just like
love you for you and whatever I think
that that helps so much you know just
knowing that you're really really cool
and awesome